okay let's go next
um let's go to tebow
from belgium tebow from belgium you're
on the air
hey david can you hear me yes i can
where in belgium are you calling from
i am calling from ghent oh beautiful
beautiful city i've been there
oh nice yes it's a large student's
population over there
so i'm still studying uh veterinary
medicine uh
so that's why i'm there now gent is the
one that has the trolley right
trolley yeah isn't there isn't there
like an elevated
subway that goes down the streets in
ghent or is that antwerp now it's all
blending together
i think you might confused with antwerp
okay all right well i apologize for that
no problem so i wanted to ask you
because i have heard
um i've been following your channel for
a couple of months right now
and i was wondering because you have
always stated that your position
on trump getting into prison after his
presidency
is very minimal but after i
i've been following the news for like
the past couple of years about trump and
the difference i am noticing
uh with european countries is that you
have one
major news channel like fox news
enabling his presidency and his
misinformation and his life yeah and
that is not something we see here in
european countries where
um opinion shows uh don't really exist
or not in such a big fashion as it does
in the us
so i'm thinking trump has had a
precedent right now
um by committing crimes inside the white
house outside the white house
and he can get away with anything he
wants but the president has already said
so if he runs again in 2024
or if a more intelligent person
a rich guy with more intellectual
capabilities than trump
runs in 2024 the president is set and he
can expand
his crimes he can expand his behavior so
i think it is important that if
trump is proven to be guilty of crimes
after he leaves the white house he
should be prosecuted
and if judge con thinks he should good
he should go to jail then i think you
should not
um prohibit that or think of it
as he is a past person a former
president so we can't do that
oh i i completely agree with you what
i've said is
i don't believe trump is going to prison
i
your analysis is spot on donald trump
has debased
the office of the presidency he's shown
that even the checks and balances
that the founders put in place never
assumed
someone who would flout these norms
the way that donald trump did and i
believe that what donald trump exposed
is that our checks and balances are not
nearly as rigorous as we imagined them
to be
your your assessment is 100 correct
i just don't believe there is really any
appetite
at the top level in the united states to
jail former presidents period that
my i was making a prediction not an
analysis your analysis
is completely correct oh okay and i'm
also like worried because
a lot of democrats i feel like in the us
are feeling like
democracy is saved right now but if
trump is going to start his own news
channel
yeah and the republican party by the way
doesn't exist anymore it's not a trump
party
so if they follow his like trump news
and all his new opinion shows he will
launch and
the wild spread misinformation then it's
gonna be
like 2016 all over again i feel like i
think you're right
and uh the issue of whether the
republican party is now simply
the trump party i think it remains to be
seen i think
i do think that if donald trump
relatively
quickly uh goes back into obscurity
which he may
we just don't know yet i think you will
very quickly see a lot in the
of people in the republican party just
sort of pretend it never happened
and go back to talking about the debt
and and
kind of the way the republican party was
before trump if trump remains
present if he starts a news network or
whatever the case may be i think it'll
be handled differently
i think we just have to wait and see on
that
yeah but the fact that like 80 percent
of uh republicans
already think that this election is
rigged yeah also says a lot about
yeah they're still republican or just
that doesn't bode well
that doesn't bode well i agree with you
okay yeah thanks for taking my call i
really appreciate it
all right my pleasure great to hear from
our friends in belgium belgium is a
one of my favorite places i've visited i
have to tell you i've been to uh
brussels bruges ghent
and antwerp and all um all amazing
places
really really great places if you love
feeding
your intellectual curiosity but you're
always struggling to find the time
check out one of my all-time favorite
apps
called blinkist blinkist lets you
consume an entire book
on your way home from work they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one into text or audio
that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect if you don't have
enough time
to do all the reading you want to do or
if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25 percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video